yes hey what's up guys
welcome back welcome back on a saturday
uh it's 11 30
here in los angeles thank you for
joining me um
man what a crazy crazy week but before i
get into how insane the week was and all
the cool stuff that came out this week
um let's just real quick just talk about
what we're gonna do today all right so
last week we made this image right here
in cinema 4d
um in octane right so we put this
together in a couple hours
and i want to bring this thing to life
right so i want to bring this cinema 4d
scene into
unreal engine and i want to get uh like
the the virtual production going the
virtual camera
so i've actually hooked up my phone to
unreal engine and we're going to be able
to
you know film a cool scene in real time
and we're going to see as a test can we
get
this quality in unreal if i if i made
this in cinema 4d
last week um and if you missed that then
there's a link
to that video in the description right
but forget about that right now we're
talking about this
so can i get this to look as good as i
made it in octane c4d
inside of unreal and then i want to add
some actual volumetric fog some
real-time volumetric fog
i want to add real-time lens flares
going on
and i want to be able to hook it up with
the phone and actually film a scene i i
think we're gonna get a little
uh ahead of ourselves if we start adding
the moths that
that attract in the light but i
certainly want to look into that as well
it's just a little deeper
than uh than i have time for today
but um hey welcome everybody let's get
into like
what happened this week because this
week was actually really big for me
um and i i'm very excited about it and i
want to share with you guys all the cool
stuff that happened
so let's go down the list here um
yeah we got unreal open all right so if
you guys
if you guys don't know um i actually put
out a
a max on presentation for their 3d
motion and design show
it's kind of uh it took place during c
graph c graph would be happening
you know this week or last week so
i put together this whole presentation
for maxon it's about 55 minutes long
i live live streamed it did a live q a
after the fact with matthias
it was absolutely incredible um there's
a lot of really fun guests a lot of
very talented guests but if you guys go
to 3dmotionshow.com
scroll down and you'll see on the first
one here the secret to photo reel visual
effects you can hit this button watch
now
and it'll take you to you know my
presentation
where i talk to you guys about how to
add in this newspaper stand
we're getting into tracking lighting
texturing
modeling compositing all the stuff that
you guys need to know
in order to achieve those photo real
composites
that we're all striving for so that was
big that was big for me it was such a
such a an honor to present on behalf of
maxon
and it was such a cool experience so
definitely check out this presentation
um it'll also be on my channel i'm gonna
try and post it next saturday
because i'm going on vacation tomorrow
i'm going to be gone
um for next saturday there will be no
live stream next saturday
but i will be posting this presentation
for you guys to have something right
next up i actually put out
an hdri tutorial on how to make custom
hdris on my channel this is the first
time
i've actually like posted a video on my
channel that isn't a live stream
in in nearly six years
that's that's craziness um that's a long
time
but i'm so proud of this video it turned
out really well
um the feedback is awesome you guys are
saying that it was very clear and
concise so that's
awesome to hear um so if you hadn't
check out this tutorial it goes over how
to light your scenes how to like
like so if like the max on presentation
was the giant overview of all the stuff
you can get into
this like zooms in on the hdri element
and how to make a custom one
because that's really how you're making
your stuff look real nice it's one of
the elements that makes it look real
nice
um all right so next
what do we have i released guys these
are endless i released a custom
hdri package right this is an hdri pack
a war zone pack a bunch of different
hdris taken
in like an apocalyptic kind of setting a
battlefield setting
indoor outdoor all that good stuff
so i know that some of you guys were
looking for ways to support that wasn't
through like a super chat or something
or buying one of my prints i know
they're a little expensive
you can go to this gum road here and
pick this
up it's eight bucks right now and you
get 14
high quality hdris and i try and keep it
unique you know i want to put out a hdri
pack that not
a lot of people are selling if i'm going
to sell something
i want it to be at least a little unique
so that's kind of
why i went with that like apocalyptic
war zone kind of feeling
um man and
and that's not it
shoot man um i worked every
night this week from 8 a.m to midnight
working on
the latest corridor video putting
together this whole
vfx fest of uh domino's
crushing and falling onto each other um
so definitely check out the latest
corridor video it's like world's biggest
uh domino run it's crazy i spent a lot
of time on it
but i'm glad to have put it out into the
world i'm very happy to have done that
because now i get to go on vacation
that's that's the best part i get to go
on vacation
and last announcement guys um once again
once again this stream is brought to you
by
our friends over at skillshare and if
you guys don't know who skillshare is by
this point i've talked about them a
whole lot
on this stream on this show they're an
online learning community for creatives
like you guys who are willing to up
their game their value
their skill level if you want to learn
whatever the heck anything you want to
learn you guys can learn it on
skillshare
it's maxed out it's awesome it's set for
any skill set
any like skill set or any schedule um
whether you want to you know learn
something quickly learn something over a
longer period of time
they got it all set for you guys and you
know like we do when i shout out
skillshare
they really are an awesome service here
i'd like to to bring up three videos or
three classes
that i think are awesome so let's start
with uh
with this guy here visual don this is
don mupassi
and he's gonna bring you guys through
the process of making these awesome like
retro loops
and i know that i i think i've shouted
him out before on one of these streams
um but his course is really sick because
like
this is a really cool technique and it's
very powerful what he's doing
he walks you through all of his whole
process in about an hour and a half
he's inside of c4d and after effects
next up we have um i know a lot of you
people are
like you you you asked me if i were to
get into 3d is blender a good option
or blender's the best i love blender so
i know there's a lot of blender folks in
here
this tutorial right here this class
right here this walks you guys through
the whole process of how to create these
photo reel
like interior spaces like this arc
design
arc visualization and it breaks down the
whole process this is a longer one this
is four and a half hours
roughly but it goes through everything
it goes through the modeling the
texturing the lighting
all this cool stuff basically my c-graph
presentation minus the tracking and the
compositing
but over four and a half hours and in
blender
and finally it all comes down at the end
of the day to lighting
because if you model something and you
texture something and it looks so good
but you don't light it correctly you
you're kind of wasting your time
so this is a kind of a different little
twist on the tutorial cider on this
class
and this is a very short one it's 25
minutes but the information that she
packs into this
is incredible and i'm actually very very
excited for this
because this information here is crucial
to know as
designers as directors we we need to
know how to light stuff and how to make
stuff
look nice and this is just a really
great breakdown of everything so that
you guys can do that
um but hey look if you guys are looking
to sign up as a skill
share member you guys get unlimited
access
to premium and regularly updated content
for less than 10 bucks a month
for an annual subscription and as usual
to the first 2 000 people who click the
link the skillshare link in the
description below
you guys get two free months of
skillshare premium on myself
go down there click the link um learn
some stuff maybe later this week
uh or or on the weekend um and get your
learn on guys because that's we're all
here to do we're here to learn and grow
together so that's it
those are the announcements for for this
stream that was a lot it was a crazy
week
i definitely need this vacation i
definitely need this vacation
so this is a nice little send-off um i
leave on sunday i'm going to nevada i'm
just going to chill
fishing hiking kayaking dune buggies
it's going to be nice um so for those of
you just hopping in
all right i'm going to go over the
overview of what we're doing today all
right
um okay we created this last week
in cinema 4d and octane i want to bring
this image
not the image i want to bring the files
obviously the models into unreal engine
and i want to see as a test can i get it
to look this good in real time
um on top of that i want to add
volumetric fog
because unreal does such a good job at
real time
volumetric fog and i want to add
this is the coolest part guys i hooked
my phone
up to unreal engine and i'm able to
actually like
film a video and have a virtual camera
that i'm holding in my hand translate to
unreal engine so you can
move around your cg objects move around
your scene and actually film a couple
like clips you can get close to it you
can control your focus settings
so huge shout out to winbush he has a
tutorial on how to do that
it helped me out a lot to set me up for
this stream today so we'll be getting
into that
uh uh what else
um i think that's it yeah that's what
we're gonna do
we're gonna just jump in man i need some
water
that was a lot so
we're inside of unreal and if you guys
don't know what unreal is um
it's pretty much it's the future it
really is
definitely check out unreal engine if
you don't know what it is i mean i'm
about to show you right now
i'm not a master i'm learning i am very
new to unreal engine as some of you guys
know i'm very very new
and i'm slowly learning but it is so
cool and so exciting so i just
i want to figure this out with you guys
together we'll figure this out
um hey there's chris thank you thank you
thank you chris
um he's actually helped me out a whole
bunch
in unreal um you've answered a lot of
questions you've actually sat down with
me and like
um and really just just helped me out
answered questions that i had
so i really appreciate it you need that
you need an unreal sensei
you know you cannot learn on your own so
my goal is to find
the people who are the best at it and to
learn from them as quickly as possible
um such as evolver interactive here or
win bush you know
these guys are incredible sam sam has
been
killing it in the unreal game he picked
it up like that so i've been learning a
lot from sam too
um a lot of exciting stuff going on
um that sam is working on with unreal so
all right the first challenge let's try
and import our cinema 4d scene
into unreal engine um
and see if we can't get it to look nice
i guess
this is all right this is when this is
when the stream takes a dip here we go
boop
let me try and figure this out okay
so i heard from y'all
correct me if i'm wrong but i heard from
y'all that uh
i could import cinema 4d scenes into
unreal engine
is that true go ahead and at punisher me
here
um in the in the live the live chat let
me know is that true for those of you
all who know the program
um joe can you share the plugin for your
phone yeah it's called uh
it's on the io it's on ios and it's
called virtual camera 2
i think is the name of it let me double
check that
it's it's called you remote um
let me find it
uh let's see virtual is it virtual
camera
or unreal
unreal remote 2. yeah there it is
if you guys can see this it's called
unreal remote 2. if you're in
[Music]
the ios store if you guys can see that
unreal remote to
boom it's just the black and white
monitor icon
so that's what you need to get that
going
but let's see if we can't import our
scene
student cinema 4d scene into this
so i know i can do fbx's with materials
maybe
i wonder but let me let me just see if i
can like import
my c4d scene i know that's in
here episode 24
wait where's my cinema 4d scene
what where did i did i save it in the
wrong place
all right let me open cinema 4d and
figure out where the heck i saved this
thing
so we can like try and import this
cinema 4d scene
oh okay i need a i need a data smith
plug-in for unreal engine
so let's let's try looking that up let's
go
let's go to the epic games launcher
and head to the marketplace and i'm just
guessing here that it's something i need
to download as far as plugins go and
we'll type in
data smith i've never used this before
we're kind of on this journey together
and i'm assuming data smith allows you
data smith export plugins
okay apparently i own this
um
our data smith plug-in import c4d scenes
now i don't know
if this is actually built in or not but
first we need to find our scene if you
guys can actually point me to the exact
thing i need
is it this one here this data smart data
smith export plugins
or is it already built into unreal in
the meantime i'm going to try and find
that scene we worked on geez all of this
stuff
all of the my most recent
cinema 4d scenes are the corridor like
uh
domino's video dude that line beginning
shot
where ren's drone knocked down those
dominoes
in the beginning like i think i lost a
couple years off my life
from that one okay let's see
um tutorials episodes
dude where is my project file c4d
did i straight up did i straight up lose
it
oh my god all right let's do one thing
at a time here i'm going to switch over
okay you're saying okay check um check
my plugins tab
all right settings plugins
um let's try data smith
and it does not look
data smith c4d importer yeah i have it
okay add support for importing content
from 740 applications in unreal engine
great yeah it looks like i have it so we
should be good to go on
that but i need to enable it and enable
data smith content okay
fbx importer why not
um let's restart okay
now dude i need to find
wow okay i need i need to find that
scene did i straight up lose the scene
that would be
so bad there's no way
there's no way is it in here
was i just so in domino world that i
like
saved it in the wrong place
dude
like this is where it should be in here
am i missing something oh this is bad
what on earth okay this this kind of
like this kind of like this is
a little crutch here because we can't do
this unless i find the scene
all right y'all bear with me all right
bear with me on this yeah i did look at
recent projects dude
it's all dominoes it's
all dominoes all right let me okay okay
okay let me check let me check something
[Music]
um
shoot
oh okay let me okay let's use this
and search everything on my computer
i think it was called lamp post or light
post
all right we're going to search
everything all right lamp
searching for lamp
scanning my drives all right um
let's see what we find
i wonder if i can just search for oh
here
recovery scene street lamp alright so
that's roaming
so it was called street lamp
look at this problem solving here it is
it's under
vfx materials 3d models personal
look at that yo
[Music]
that's cool all right so this is i think
this is called search everything
is the name of this and it totally just
saved me
that's awesome sweet okay let me frickin
save this in the right place now because
my goodness
that was bad wasn't it
hey uh mr damn that's not a bad idea
check the last live stream
not a bad idea at all all right let's go
let's save this in the right spot here
guys episodes
we're in episode 25. yeah let's do that
all right all right so
data smith do i just need to go do i
just import or have to import through
data smith let's figure this out
we're learning together all right we're
learning and growing together
i'm no unreal engine master i'm just
messing around
trying to push through the problem
solving here we go
episode 25 all right so it doesn't show
up here
file um is there like a data smith
window perhaps
um settings plugins
will go
let's see data smith
yo christopher hey thank you for the
super chat
he says thanks for doing these streams
appreciate the time you put in showing
us a bit into your work absolutely no
problem man this is for you guys
thank you so much all right data smith
button is at the top of the viewport
yes um
well it's data smith yeah hey thank you
thank you thank you
y'all rock learning so much
episode 25 street lamp
choose location for importing davesmith
content
starter content let's go uh new folder
c4d boom let's do it
we want everything we want geometry
materials and textures no doubt let's
bring the lights in just to see what
happens
the camera why not and i don't have any
animations
static mesh options light map resolution
light map uh
minimum light map maximum light map
generate light map
uvs let's just
import by default and see what happens
there
um vincent i'm so glad that that you
think that my last unreal streams have
been helpful
um i i i am scrambling
to learn this program man so i'm really
glad that you feel that way
it's stressful it is certainly stressful
okay we have our lamp
post and we have some geometry
but we don't have our wires do i have to
actually save
the wires out as geometry inside of
cinema 4d
um yeah it's all of my like uh
all my splines that were turned into
uh like sweep sweep lines and whatnot
those are gone so i think i might just
have to go back to c4d
and bake out like an fbx with materials
this doesn't have materials though
so c4d street lamp materials
this is just bringing in like my
background and stuff it's not bringing
in
the materials that i had
huh okay
textures no okay so tech it's not doing
it in textures geometry
it has um
[Music]
like our nuts and bolts and stuff it
certainly has our screws and our nuts
and bolts i don't think it's a showing
yeah it's got that it's definitely
missing some stuff you know
there's like there's like cubes i think
it might be
stuff that is still um in its primitive
form
in c4d so let me
let me try and just bust out like an fbx
real quick
and see if that has any difference
with like a default import so let's just
run that test
so we're in here we're back in cinema 4d
and let's just go let's clean this up
real quick
so let me bring in my octane
where are you at stream there we go
materials
let's remove unused materials boom all
right cool
and now we'll go file export and let's
do
fbx okay
we want geometry
um animation we don't have materials
bake the materials do i need to unwrap i
probably need to unwrap this but
we'll find out one step at a time
boom street lamp fbx awesome
back in unreal
let's go ahead and
let's delete this from our scene so i'm
just gonna i'm not gonna undo
and maybe not undo the import but let's
just
close out the street lamp
actor is referenced by other actors do
you want to delete it it will break the
references
reference list
yeah that's fine i think
octane light yeah let's get rid of these
gone yes to all
okay so there's still a lot of stuff
that it imported which is nice
but i'm just missing uh
there's a lot of stuff to delete then
this is almost too much
all right so then i'm just going to
shift click all of this
boom delete that yes to all
and it looks like that's everything
maybe except for some of this stuff get
rid of that
we can get rid of our camera
and let me just pop into a new level
time of day yep cool don't need to save
any of that
i swear i started like this okay and
let's import the fbx
so let's go import
street lamp is the fbx let's take a look
at our settings
material
create new materials
create new instance materials why not
i think if that if i'm imagining this
correctly
you're gonna have like your master
material and then you'll have your
instance material where you can actually
quickly adjust that stuff that's what i
learned last two weeks
or two weeks ago so hopefully that's the
case i'm going to import all and just
see what happens here
trial and error baby all right chris
what am i doing wrong
faster to close and not save faster to
close and not save and just reopen when
the scenes get too many data smith
assets
i see just start fresh
alright so it imported everything
it looks like i brought it brought our
sweeps in i also learned from
last two or two weeks ago that you could
select
all of this geometry and drag it out
and it should stick together and look at
that
it does
all right so i just dropped it into our
scene
and this is roughly the angle that we
had something like this
i cannot wait to bust out the phone
and get this like virtual um
like the virtual camera setup going
materials man
that's the thing where are my materials
and i need to group all this stuff
so group is that
the right thing is it group no i don't
think it is i need to put it into a
folder
um browse
i mean i guess i could just create a
folder
oh man right click create folder
where did it go i do not know
i guess there it is
lamp post street lamp that's what it's
called
street lamp geo
and we'll drag all of that stuff
into that folder i'm sure there's a
faster way to do this i'm sure there's a
hotkey for that
scoring you don't think i exported with
materials from c4d
let's render this octane scene just to
be sure we got our materials
all right just to be just to be sure
yeah we got our materials
file export fbx
oh none
all right yeah that's me then
let's try it again
christian yo thanks dude
welcome back i appreciate you man thanks
for coming back
dude everything's going great man i am i
am so excited for those of you guys just
jumping in
i had so much stuff going on this week
man so much stuff go on this week
i had an hdri custom hdri tutorial that
i posted on my channel
first video that i've actually produced
in like five years on my channel
i released an hdri uh warzone pack
on gumroad uh the link to that is in the
description
um i finished the corridor video the
domino's
world's biggest domino chain video that
was this week i did a max on
presentation this week
so much so much is going on and i go on
vacation tomorrow for a week so i'm
i'm happy this is this is the victory
round right here with you guys
all right let's try this again let's try
this again i'm gonna delete all this
crap
i'm just gonna be like yo you know what
gone
force delete i don't care watch
so i'm not using octane in c4 or um i am
not using octane in unreal engine right
now
i'm just default unreal engine it was
kind of the same way i was with
cinema 4d at first i was like default
freaking physical renderer scan line
i want to learn it from the ground up
that was a mistake i should have just
hopped right into octane because i don't
use that stuff anymore i don't use
physical or scanline like who uses
scanline
what are you doing um so
ren tried to talk me into octane for a
long time i was like nah i'm gonna
i'm gonna learn it from the ground up i
wanna learn everything and i was having
a good time you know
um so i don't know maybe i should use
octane
in in unreal but i thought the whole
point of unreal engine was the real time
graphics but i guess if you have the
ability to
i have octane in unreal like why not
it's just another tool on the tool belt
you know
i'm still learning i'll figure it out
i'll figure out the right workflow i
know
i know evolver is uh
is into octane with with unreal so
yeah we'll see where that goes let's
import it for real this time guys we've
tried
we've tried three times and we're gonna
try it again
and we're gonna get this freaking right
i'm not sad
i i'm not like i'm no longer holding
myself
to the idea that these streams have to
be perfect when it comes to unreal
engine
okay um i get it
you know i'm learning so let's import
with materials this time
okay materials local create
um new instance materials
and i think we're going to import all
no dude yeah okay import all import all
yeah this is just so exciting this whole
weekend
like my mind has been elsewhere um
and i guess for the last two weeks my
mind has been elsewhere
but i'm just so excited to be back in
unreal so excited
there's been a lot of cool stuff there's
like a zen garden one that came out a
zen garden short film that came out with
unreal so that was awesome
i want to be a part of that i want to
start adding to this photo real
shorts that come out online that people
are like what
so that's my goal certainly certainly my
goal
okay it brought in materials they're all
white
is it because it doesn't know where the
path is
or what but we'll figure that out in a
second
one problem at a time right now we need
to delete
all of this old geometry
get rid of that let's bring in the new
geometry
boom so that's in
now i wonder does it come with we don't
need the
ground plane floor go away
get rid of that actually you know what
let's get rid of the floor who needs a
floor
i'm just going to rock this thing here
boom this plane this is my floor
and let's fix our our uh
our um auto exposure settings here you
can see how like
it's stopping down and stopping up so i
think the quickest way is to go to this
little drop down
and no no go to lit uncheck game
settings
is ev100 default
or is this
so you can just set this however you
want exposure there
sweet okay and let's see okay brought in
all of our lines
yeah it brought in our little cubes and
if the camera is too fast for you
i'm holding right click and using wasd
to move around
you can go up here to the camera speed
and i think you can
middle mouse button for this but i have
a a pen
so my middle mouse button got to figure
that one out just drop down that
sensitivity and now you can kind of get
closer to this stuff
i don't know how to fix the clipping
issue there
um but that's not really the big of an
issue for us right now
and you can use q and e to go um to boom
up and down
okay um g will hide all of your like
icons and stuff
and this gets us like this gets us close
i know that we were at a 24.
we our camera was at 24. um
i can't wait to get the phone set up
it's gonna be so nice
all right um
what's next materials let's just let's
just go into one of these and figure out
what's going on
so we have nothing
nothing all right and i'm wondering if
it's because i did the instance material
or what
i don't know why but like this rusted
metal
should be some rusted metal you know not
it's just it's just white
right now so i don't i don't know what's
wrong with that
evolver do you have any tips on that
on why my materials aren't importing
properly
one of these materials is from mega
scans
this wooden paneling the other materials
are from um
grayscale gorillas everyday material
pack
those textures i mean the textures are
on my computer
and it doesn't look like it's having an
issue where it's like i can't find the
textures
they're just not even they're not even
here
so it's not it's not importing them
properly i feel like
stake lp what is this called this
program is called unreal engine it's a
real time
uh graphics like uh program you can make
video games you can make
awesome cutscenes and you can run your
scene in real time
so i know at a certain point i'm gonna
have to turn on rtx
um or ray tracing and that's gonna take
a minute to open up i know
last time it took us like 15 minutes so
i'm definitely gonna be looking out for
like a 15-minute gap where
we can we can set that up
all right why is that cube there that's
gross
we're gonna get a light up in here
oh it didn't import some stuff like i
know there's a couple lines that it
didn't import
yeah that's fine
let's get a camera going um
all right so evolver you say you send
your materials
over via octane because of this issue
are you saying you use octane inside of
unreal
i think we can we can quickly texture
this it's just one wood texture
and some like metal texture with a light
i don't think that's that bad you know
like i think i learned enough
from the last two weeks to be able to
figure out how to make a texture
uh in unreal here
and i can always rework the textures you
know and make them really nice
but that was our test our test was to
see if we can get this look
right here um in
unreal engine and right now by like a
default kind of base import of this
material or of this scene
we're not getting the textures and
that's a big that's a big problem
so i'm gonna have to troubleshoot that
and figure that one out
and yeah okay i'm gonna bring in the
textures and do the node setup so maybe
let's just try that with this wood
paneling then
um and let's figure out where this stuff
sits on my desktop
or on my computer we're gonna locate it
in octane
and here we are now let's see
i should be able to just drag these in
and i know this is bridge and i should
be using my bridge plug-in
but uh i ain't gonna do that right now
because i don't have the bridge plug-in
installed because something happened
actually really quick let me just check
um
bridge bridge nothing let me open bridge
and then this update man like i get hit
with that update i think something's up
with bridge
and i try and update but it never wants
to update properly
oh man beautiful beautiful beautiful
love
love this site okay um so if i click on
any one of these
i should be able to scroll down
download settings
or is it export do i have to export is
it export settings
i want to go to unreal engine and it's
not giving me the
the like install or update whatever
installation folder is that what i need
to
get right now's not the time to problem
solve this though guys
let's just um let's learn how to do this
let's learn how to make a material
so i'm just going to delete all of these
ones because
forced delete get out of here gone
this one gone
okay i'm going to right click we're
going to go
material
new material this is going to be called
just wood
paneling no spaces
would that's fine let's go in
oh i think i need to drag and drop
my textures so let me uh
let me just do this right
we'll make a new folder
textures and i'm just going to drag
all of this stuff in this is the wood
paneling texture from mega scans let's
drag all that into textures
and i just want to get the specular the
normal the roughness
color and the bump i don't think i need
anything else
still importing
yeah dream la that's a good question
does octane and unreal engine
work in real time
i don't know i wonder i bet you i bet
you evolver knows though
all right we're still importing i don't
know why it's taking so long
there we go all right let's make that
new material here
call this wood let's go in
and we'll just drag and drop our color
our bump
our gloss specular and normal let's drop
those in
boom
let's see if i remember anything
from what we did chris i might need your
help on this let's go rgb that goes
right into
base color
okay um the
let's see let's see what is this this is
bump
all right that's gonna go right into
[Music]
honestly i don't know where that goes i
know normal goes into normal
let's do that and we got
our
specular i'm just going to go right into
specular
our gloss
goes into roughness and i believe this
is
inverted gloss
should be in the the uh the opposite of
roughness
nothing for now on bump okay got you
all right so this is this is close let's
go and delete the bump
and let's see what what we got here i'm
going to close
this down oh we're going to save i'm
pretty sure we need to save this
close that and i think if we make uh
create material instance wood instance
we can quickly make adjustments here on
the fly to this
if we have things to adjust but let's go
ahead and apply this wood instance to
our lamp post
that's not bad that's not bad at all um
i want to get like a rusted metal kind
of texture
so let's do um
let's go back to c4d and figure out what
i was using for that this rusted metal
i'm gonna go in here and it looks like
it's having trouble finding some of
these materials
so
i actually know where they are so let's
do
let me find these real quick bear with
me guys thank you
man i was horribly placed all right so
this is my rusted metal and my rubber
for the um the wires and stuff cool
so back in
let's actually rename this textures
folder
to wood paneling
that's wood
this would be way faster with the bridge
plug-in i recognize this guys
i recognize it
i'm just amped for this phone i mix i'm
so amped to hook this phone
up to unreal i got it working before the
stream
so that's going to be freaking sweet and
the volumetric light once we get this
texturing done like in the next like 20
minutes
oh it's going to be nice we're gonna get
the lighting going we're gonna get that
freaking camera going
all right let's do um
[Music]
let's make a new fold now get get
get
all right new folder this is gonna be
called
uh metal bam metal
sweet let's go into metal and let's just
drop
let's drop our corroded stained metal
iron corroded or do we want rusted metal
yeah that's what we want we want that
rusty and we'll drag and drop those
evolver you're talking about the bridge
setup all right
here's the thing with bridge it was
working and then it wasn't all right it
just all of a sudden
did not work um i'm down
if y'all are down and you want to set up
bridge right now
let's do it with evolver if you want to
walk us through that
um my issue
is if i go to bridge
this dude okay this download
all right this download keeps hitting me
i hit download now and what does it do
it thanks for a minute and it downloads
the update downloading update
okay
and then and then and then what and then
what it just stops
it just sits there i don't know what to
do there's not even a progress bar
what's going on here
i had it working i had it working
oh man yeah i might just have to clean
just freaking uninstall all right hey
i'm gonna let that go i'm gonna let this
download update go and we're gonna come
back okay wait
okay it's gone it's disappeared
so i have to reinstall you guys don't
want to watch me reinstall bridge we
don't need to be reinstalling bridge
right now okay
let's holster that for a second all
right we're not touching it
we're in we're going back in let's make
right click
new fold no delete right click
new material what's this called rusted
metal
boom all right we're in
materials in textures on
all right what do we got what do we got
what we got
normal into the normal tab
base color you know where you're going
um
rusted metal metal so this is the
metallic bam
let's go metallic on that is this just
looking good
it's just looking good all right um
roughness roughness
you know where to go that's i mean
that's
it dude i'm not complaining i'm not
gonna complain now i
might complain a little bit about like
the mapping of this thing
um how i know that you guys taught me
how to how to scale down the texture
so i'm gonna keep my eyes peeled for
that make sure you save all right
definitely save
[Music]
uh devin will you be working on creating
landscape and landscape materials in the
future for unreal yes absolutely i want
to create the most
epic um real-time photo real landscapes
all right evolver i'll just delete the
user app data roaming
bridge and delete all right i'll handle
that after the fact
let's close this though um rusted metal
where are you going where are you going
okay rest the middle let's do
uh the material instance it's going to
run faster this way
we can make edits faster this way and
look at that we got some stuff there
it doesn't it's not as shiny as i'd like
but dang i have to go through every
single one of these and drop this
texture in
let's do a test can we select
one
and i'm gonna i'm hitting q and e to
boom
up holding shift selecting two
three and i want to just select all of
these
it's the footholds it's all these
footholds so if i just
shift click all the footholds in here in
theory i should be able to just drag and
drop
and it should okay it's not
it's not applying to all of them what if
i okay i can't do that
um can i right click and apply to select
it or something
okay so i can select objects using this
asset yeah the pull steps are shiny
agreed
select all and right click select all by
selected class
select all and right click
oh my god select all the same material
merge the actors merge the actors
okay select all and right click
merge the actors
convert to static mesh
no
okay normally you combine them in cinema
i'm trying to merge all these into one
so i can just drag this one rest of
material into everything
detail panel on the left detail panel
on the left
where are you detail panel
see this is this is the boring part
details panel
ah
okay that's not working
detail panel on the bottom right okay um
selected viewport convert to static mesh
was right
convert to static mesh was right okay
let's try
convert to static mesh just hit okay
so does that mean if i delete all of
these
and then i drag this back into the scene
that's the one okay that's just like one
mesh then
and this should be what zero zero
if i zero this out
zero zero zero
jeez okay so i would just have to like
line that up
this is such a janky way of doing this
jeez um content
metal rusted metal
and that applies it to
everything so now they all have it
okay no what
dude
how okay that has it
that has it that has it
that doesn't have it
good
yes no
you know i'ma learn i'ma learn
but not today at least i'm not at least
not even
at least not now
i know y'all are screaming at me i can
see the chat
i see you guys
but we don't want to get hung up we
don't want to get hung up we want to get
to the end i want to get to that virtual
camera set up all right i'm gonna glance
over
all right infiltrato and the next the
materials you made in c4d are exported
to a real um to a real even though
they're empty but each material is
applied to an object if you work with
those empty materials would be applied
to all the objects that had materials by
default
ben smith welcome i do have my own
youtube channel thanks for joining
the material was below that so i was
i was going in the wrong thing is what
you're saying
i was dropping into static mesh like a
dum-dum
and i needed to be dropping it into this
right here
boom boom this is what i needed right
and if i had selected them all i
probably could have just
dropped them all in all right
good to know all right what's next um
[Music]
rusted metal on
this box maybe
so it looks stretched i think that's
certainly a uv thing um
i wonder how much you're gonna notice
though
you probably would yeah these uvs are
off let me
you can yeah it's it's certainly
stretched
and it would take me unwrapping all this
stuff
let's try another material i'm going to
make
one more two more i'm going to do this
iron corroded and i'm going to do the
rubber
and that's what i'm using for the ropes
or for the um the wires
let's make a new folder no not in that
folder
metals going in woods going in
yeah this program is deep guys but it
just takes messing around in it
metals okay that goes material move all
right
yeah you just gotta jump in and mess
around with stuff and
i i i'm trying to be entertaining here
for you guys i don't want uh
i don't want to sit here silently and
just click away at things like that's
gonna be a boring stream so i'm trying
to ride the balance of like
entertainment and also education here um
let's go into materials we'll make a new
folder
and we're gonna do um iron and then
we're gonna have one more and that's
going to be
um our rubber
we'll do rubber let's go or no
iron let's do iron these four
let's drop those in
ugh
yeah john malcolm i need to get on that
i need to like definitely know what i'm
doing when it comes to unwrapping
there's a whole lot of stuff i don't
know um i know just enough to get by
okay let's uh let's go back
no um content yes all right we want
materials
and i also want this
rubber
right here let's go rubber we'll drop
that into the rubber folder
yeah so much of vfx is problem solving
and troubleshooting and that's just
that that's just what it is like that's
how you learn at least for me
like i have to be able to just kind of
mess around in a program
and and and work real slow you're
crawling
from the beginning you are just trying
to stand
up but the more you do it um the more
you practice
eventually you get to the point where
you can fly around the program and
that's
that's when you feel like a master it's
just like you're unstoppable you know
so let's go new material we're gonna go
rubber and we're just gonna do what we
did i'm gonna set these up real quick
and this is cool man i'm like i'm
applying the stuff that i was learning
from uh
from two weeks ago's stream i couldn't
i couldn't do this stuff before i could
barely even open the materials and drag
stuff in i didn't know what was going on
roughness all right we save it
give it a close all right so that's
rubber and that's going to be on all of
our wires
so that's on our wires and
these like little these little housings
and let's just make the uh the iron and
we're going to apply this we're going to
try and use what we learned
and do this a little bit faster iron in
yo are any of you guys playing the last
of us too
because that game is freaking crazy
right now i know i'm a little behind
but uh i mean i've been so busy i
honestly hadn't been able to play too
much
but i'm about 10 hours in and dude that
game is crazy
i love it and then i'm going to get
ghost of tsushima too
after i beat that those are my games for
this year definitely
all right so i'll keep that in mind
unwrapping is pretty much mandatory
when doing all this stuff yeah that's
because that's not going to look pretty
i'm i'm very used to um
being an octane right and inside of
octane
you can set up the projection mapping
per material so i just set it to box and
then i control the scale from there per
material
but i don't really know that workflow in
that setup here
um
all right so that's shiny it's shiny but
it's not
that's not the best
it doesn't look as good as it does in
octane for me
so i think really getting that bridge
setup going is going to help a whole
bunch
yeah that doesn't that just doesn't look
good
once you have the bridge setup going i
think you can kind of learn
the setup learn how it's done and this
definitely needs to be unwrapped
is it too late i don't think it's too
late
all right if i learned anything from
last uh from two weeks ago or three
weeks ago at this point
we'll go to the uv
edit panel okay
i have everything selected
or not to make stuff editable
let me just try this let me let me
duplicate my geometry
holding control and hit the plus sign
i'm going to select everything
this might be dumb this may not work but
let's try it i'm going to select
everything all right i'm going to right
click connect plus delete
and now we have all this geometry
and what was the
automatic pack uvs i think is what we
did
hit okay and it's thinking down here and
there you go
our uvs are unwrapped
and i think if i apply
a if i go back to my normal setup
if i apply like a checkerboard
effect here where you at checkerboard
i guess that's right here let me try
scaling it
we'll scale it down
and get rid of all these materials
tags we don't need and let's take this
and tile it like
three times and it looks a little scaled
but i think it's a lot better than it
was before oh god i think i'm in unreal
navigation wise um there we go
yeah it's a little off but it's it's a
lot better
that's a lot better
so let me take this i'll delete
delete the light
let me export this i don't need to
export materials
and actually i don't need to export any
of this other stuff
i just want the geometry
so export that fbx
no materials
unwrapped
let's bring that guy in unwrapped coming
in
materials we don't need
yeah i was merging objects into one
and let's see if this works
yo i just realized though
i i just merged all the materials into
one so
now
now i can't apply materials to this
because there's gonna be one thing dude
it's gonna be one freaking
thing
what am i doing
let's just get to it though let's just
freaking
get to it i i don't know how to mess
with like
we'll have both in the scene why not
let's get our wires going okay
um
[Music]
let's chill on that for a second
so i want to select all of my sweeps
so all this sweep
are basically all of my wires and stuff
so let's see if we can do this right
materials okay rubber bam
yep and it's applied cool
so i'll go through and i'll just make
sure i get everything
[Music]
um materials boom yep
there might be some that i missed up
here
all up my camera sensitivity i can fly a
little bit faster
yep that's applied that's all applied
sweet
and then i need like i need the i need
metal on these guys
so these are cubes
and those could use maybe uh the rusted
metal
and these screws also all these loft
objects
same deal for the materials and there
might be a couple things we missed but
let's see if we can get that volumetric
fog going
and mess with uh
ray tracing too
all right so let's try and make it
nighttime
daylight alright so i know that if i
actually adjust
the directional light i should be able
it should be able to go yep
night time
and when i was in octane
i actually used an hdri just a gray
background but this is actually kind of
cool i like this lighting is nice
and that's the beauty of this is like
you can adjust all this stuff on the fly
that looks super cool let me bust out a
camera
so we'll do cinematic we'll bust out a
cine uh cine camera actor and i want to
pilot it so i'll right click and pilot
i know i was on a 24
what is happening let's maybe
undo all that for a second
yo what happened
am i piloting the telephone pole
i'm piloting the telephone pole guys
wow all right let's reset let's reset
that mess
all right i think that's back to normal
that was bad that was bad uh ctrl shift
s we're going to save all
ctrl alt s um no control
s what is it save all levels
yeah let's just do that
lamp street street lamp
boom all right we want to get a light up
here and we want to get that volumetric
lighting going um but let's let's try
this again okay
let me go back to my directional light
let's find that let's mess with it a
little bit
something like this
and let's try again let's get the cinema
cine camera actor out
i'm going to right click it up here in
the world outliner
let's pilot it and now we should be good
to go
i know that i want this to be a 30 or a
24
as far as focal length goes
something like that is similar to how we
had it in
octane
that's already pretty sweet heck yeah
okay let's
hop out of the camera stop piloting i
like that angle
and let's get that let's get a light
going up on here
so we'll go to lights and i think
a spot what do you think spotlight or
let's try a spotlight
i want to get it right right in here
and i wonder oh there we go yeah why is
the exposure so bright
let's hop in pilot
and let's go ahead and grab a post
uh what is it called post process volume
let's drag that in
we'll scroll all the way down and make
sure we check infinite extent so all the
changes we make in the post process
volume
happen across the entire image um
and i want to go to exposure and we
already set this with the game settings
here i'm going to
check that back on and i'm going to set
it here
in the post process volume and i'm
wondering if that'll fix the camera so
max and min brightness let's go one and
one
and then we'll go where is it we'll go
select the camera let's stop
piloting and yeah that that does it
so that's dark but we need to light it
up with that spotlight
i thought we had one spotlight
okay source radius uh
intensity
so we'll crank that intensity the light
color will make just slightly
what do we want to go with maybe like a
a warm something like warm tone
the inner cone angle see i wish i could
see
i wish i could see um the cone angle and
stuff
inner cone angle
outer cone angle
yeah that feels right
sweet
now why okay i i need to have the light
actually
showing up in the street lamp
um do i want to do this with a point
light
like is that what i'm missing
and that works actually that actually
that actually works
and we'll turn off snapping for position
um let's see it's one of these enables
are disabled snapping to the grid when
dragging objects around
yes there we go
f will snap you to the actual
object selected
all right yeah that's that's better
let's go back into our camera
control shift p
for some reason
okay there we go it's working all right
now here here's where
we step things up i think the uh
i think this directional light no no
it's the spotlight
i'm getting a weird lighting thing here
but i think we just need to bake our
lighting
let me save files
uh what is it
save current as save all levels
boom
okay
let's go ahead and draw drag in some fog
this will be
fog exponential i think it's exponential
height fog is what we want
that's awesome let's take the fog
density
let's yeah we can leave it there i think
it says check box down here we'll scroll
down and go to volumetric fog we'll
click that
scattering distribution we'll set that
to two
fog density we'll set that to two
all right that's really intense but
we're not getting those rays we want and
the fog
scattering color we could do something
like a greenish that's i feel like
that's not
doing much for us
evolver appreciate you man thank you
thank you very much
all right spooky sketches if you want to
constantly monitor your camera view
without moving it
click the pin that appears on the
preview when you select the camera
all right so i'm inside of it so i need
to hop out of it
there's the pin
so that's a weird streak going on there
when i move around i get that nasty
streak and i'm still not feeling it i'm
still not feeling this vibe right now
it definitely needs to be darker
oh evolver okay g on the key i thought
you're saying g on the keyboard to like
hide um to hide my stuff
i got you
i got you there we go thank you that's
cool
thank you evolver
so let me get this lighting right let me
try and like uh
adjust this fog it's certainly too
bright
i wonder if i just need to drop my sun
completely out
so if i do my directional light if i get
rid of that
and i go to let's see exponential height
fog
that's certainly lightening up
everything
i don't need it to be that intense so is
it the density that needs to come down
it looks like it's the density
wow point one
oh this is nice this is nice
yeah let's put the lighting um we'll go
lighting production quality
and there was another there's like
there's a lot of cool settings i learned
a lot of settings
when i was messing around with all this
stuff let's build it
see what happens
all right in both of your lights
increase the scattering to add light
shafts through the fog
yes i certainly think that this is like
pretty intense overkill
um as far as like the fog goes but it is
it is a look
it is certainly a look i need to
just learn to program more get more
familiar with like what things do when
it comes to lighting and stuff
wow that is bright
definitely some silent hill vibes
all right martha lars says all of my
objects
have a second uv channel which are
holding the light maps the light gets
baked into these uv maps you have to
make sure the res is high enough and the
uvs are generated well
um okay so does that mean i have to go
into
all of these materials and adjust oh
this light map have to adjust all this
stuff
that's a lot
that's a lot
so many settings i'll learn these
settings man that's there's just so many
yeah i think it's time to enable ray
tracing
we did it last time it takes about 15
minutes i think i can actually announce
the uh the winners
wallet while it goes into ray tracing
there
but this is an interesting setup i
definitely think
it's too bright though so i'm wondering
like we could either bring down
i feel like this is the wrong way to do
it
to bring down the exposure yeah that's
definitely the wrong way to do it
but we could go to our post process
volume and start messing with all this
stuff
so we want to enable ray tracing
um
[Music]
if i remember correctly it would be in
project settings it's in here
somewhere
rendering scroll down
dude sid thank you so much i certainly
will on vacation i leave tomorrow
on vacation so i i will indeed thank you
sir
physics now was it physics no it
couldn't be physics
um engine
[Music]
where was it so you do this once like
two weeks ago
and you forget how to do it it should be
in here
virtual as textures reflections lighting
post process default settings
optimization
yeah i think ray tracing will be sweet
engine ray tracing ray tracing here we
go um
yes cool i'm gonna restart in a second
and then i think it was like direct
there was another option for like direct
x something that needed to be enabled
yeah i'm trying to find the rtx option
so i got rtx enabled
i need to restart but there's like a
directx thing
also do i need to do that as well
i forget exactly is it like it's under
window or something
scrolling through the settings
yeah directx 12 i need how do i enable
directx 12
when yeah platforms windows
here we go
all right let's save
everything and restart
save selected all right
let it begin we'll see we'll see what it
does
how it changes things up let's close
cinema all right now while that goes
it's going to stay 39 percent for a
while we we
hold on
is it just gonna is it just gonna go all
quick i mean with the compile shaders
but i don't really have that much stuff
going on
and then yeah i'll definitely mess with
the ray trace the options and post
process volume
all right so hey while this goes while
we compile shaders
i'm gonna go ahead and announce the
winners of this week's weekly challenge
um i was very impressed with this week's
weekly challenge
i think there was a ton of amazing
amazing entries the challenge was lego
that was the challenge i issued to you
guys
and there was actually so many cool
entries that i just want to go through
all of them with you while we compile
shaders there so let's
let's hop into the discord real quick
just make sure yeah i'm in the right
place sweet
so yeah let's just go through these man
like
this is hilarious there's so much great
work that was done that you guys put
into this this is awesome
wait is this all just legos it always
has been
boom freaking killing with a little
laser gun
and you got your studio setting your
studio hdris here this is awesome
i love your background too the cartoony
stars are those also legos
very impressed very impressed
you got your classic meme set up here
oh real quick that was by uh kaipo
saipo and then this one is huffin
prinzip these names y'all
this is ridiculous recreating memes and
legos
freaking visual though with this
crushing the game as usual i don't know
if you
if you got this pack if you got like a
star wars lego pack but dude this looks
nice congratulations on this man um
very very very nice
uh mathis with a cool like lego train
set up here got your motion blur looking
nice
um we have a blade runner recreation by
breach
this is amazing there's just there's so
much good stuff here
render warrior i know you're watching
right now at least i think you are
you did this you put together this
freaking lego pack of my stream
this is hilarious this is me
with my bone phones and my kombucha and
the cats this is gilbert and teddy
well teddy is technically larger than
gilbert and he's gray but
all good dude all good you got your
speakers mouse and keyboard you forgot
the pen
and tablet but hey all good dude i love
this is this is great putting all this
together
um we have this drakon uh 12
335 like samurai dojo scene you put
together with legos
um a delorean with legos
who is this bgi yeah
this is awesome freaking sweet
yeah i just want to shout everybody out
here because they put in so much work
this is super cool it's like lego
building
amazing blaster with this
with this like it was like a mech
warrior lego that's super cool
you got your lighthouse render made out
of legos
like the clay render 2 i think honestly
i think the clay render looks awesome
i love that
yeah we'll get into this this is this is
incredible
[Music]
um
warlock making a camera out of legos
like a tiny little camera that's super
cool
you got another blade runner scene
that's actually kind of funny we got two
blade runner scenes
this one's by shelter from the original
getting those noodles
awesome we got castle right here
lego castle by mr sue yogg
sharp aluminum flavor with this epic
scene
this is freaking cool
what else we got a nice car here
everyone just put together all this
great work it's by rats
clone cloning with this gritty lego leg
texture
um malto with a cool house
glass house made out of legos and
flex uh what is your name flex 797 with
this star wars scene
yeah there's good stuff and then this
here ix productions
dropping legos that's awesome
i love that you got your surface
imperfections on the ground this is
super cool
so yeah there's a lot of good stuff
a lot of really really solid stuff here
um
with this week's weekly challenge i
think you guys had a ton of fun with
this
it was really cool watching all these
come in but let's get down to the five
winners all right and then
we'll check in we got 188 shaders left
to compile and we'll open up our level
um
okay so the winners of this week's
weekly challenge we'll just start from
the bottom and scroll up
let me check my notes here
and the first winner is visual how could
you not win look at this man
you you win like every other week
because the work you put out is just
incredible
man this is so good so
nice yeah your lighting and your scene
set up your
your composition everything you got your
elements down man congratulations
you are a winner of this week's weekly
challenge and you know what
as a prize to all the winners i will
send you guys
my hdri warzone pack that i put together
last week it's a pack full of like 14
custom hdris i'll send those out as the
prize
for y'all for the five winners um just
reach out to me on on discord here
after the stream and i'll get you guys
set up with all that stuff
uh the next winner is breach you have
won with your blade runner
2049 recreation this is awesome man
so cool yeah you got your surface
imperfections going
let's bring this up full screen you got
your surface imperfections on your legos
your camera work is really nice
camera settings are great the only gripe
all right this is cool again service
imperfections nice
the only gripe i have is this freaking
sunspot up here dude
like raise it up a little bit you know
you're trying to
you're clipping that out it just really
like is
pushing the limits of your your camera
and you can tell so i would get that up
and out of there
um let me let me reference the example
right here there is no bright hot
sunspot
um deacons is the man roger deakins is
like the king when it comes to lighting
so
follow the lead you know no white spot
there get rid of that
don't need it alright next up next up
let's see who's next
oh draken you were close you were close
dude
this was nice and honestly this uh
this delorean was close i thought this
was cool it just needed a bit more
spice on the render and it needed a bit
more color more light
a little bit more production on the
render side of things
this is probably my favorite render that
you have
but yeah it was just grayscale you know
it could use some color correction and
whatnot but
you were close man very close
but the next winner is gold this is such
a nice
render you did like an incredible job
putting this together it looks like it
was shot with a really nice camera
unbelievable your pieces are legit you
did a really nice job
and you have a second render this lego
tower
which just looks super cool i love this
so much
so gold congratulations you're going to
get that hdri warzone pack
and as well as
breech you got that hdri warzone pack as
well i'll be sending those to you guys
reach out on discord after the stream
next up next winner
i mean how could it not be zak fb
studios
because look at this look at this
and it's got full sound and everything
you guys will just have to make sure you
check it out
on the discord server
but dude this is like straight up lego
movie quality
look at your camera settings look at
your lighting
the way the way you animate this stuff
the stop motion animation
holy crap one more time
this is so good
yeah this is next level for sure
what's up melanie no the stream is not
over we're gonna hop back into unreal
and check our uh
our ray tracing settings but yeah there
you go man
like zac fb studios congratulations
you're a winner of the weekly challenge
this week well deserved you get the hdri
warzone pack my custom hdri
pack for you and last
up who do we have
last up it was it was tough you all did
really well
but it comes down to sharp aluminum
flavor
with this composition right here man
like you put a lot of work into this i
can tell
your composition is really nice your
lighting is really nice your colors are
really nice
um i'm trying to figure out like what's
going on it looks like some sort of
sci-fi like
loading bay or loading garage of some
sort a machine room there's a reactor
here i don't know what this guy's up to
he's checking it out
um and then you have a hand back here
pulling one of these lego figures out is
it a lego factory is that what's going
on is it a clone factory
the more i look at it the more questions
i have
but this is an awesome piece of work i
think your lighting and everything is
really nice
i i would say though
like definitely render out your stuff
with more samples
it looks a little crunchy here um
i think you could and it looks like you
like sharpened this really hard or
something i can't tell
but yeah i mean it's an image right let
it go overnight
throw it to like five 10k samples for an
image
um there's no reason not to but this
just looks so good dude congratulations
two sharp aluminum flavor and uh
visual breech gold zac fb studios
sharp aluminum flavor y'all
congratulations for winning
the challenge this week you guys will be
getting my
custom hdri warzone pack
and if you guys want to if you guys do
want to support uh the pack
is in the description down below it's
only eight bucks
14 awesome like hdris
um yeah great work guys really great
work i'm gonna issue
the weekly challenge this week's weekly
challenge
after we check out what we got in unreal
so we have ray tracing ray tracing is
enabled
let's um let's open up our level
oh did i not even need to compile like 2
000 shaders because i just have this
little scene here
who knows probably
but it's all good we announced the
winners it was fun
so i think we have ray tracing going
let's mess with some of our settings and
i feel like
we're not gonna um
get too big of a of a change with ray
tracing on this just because
we don't have a ton of ton of bounce
light but we'll see here
let's uh let's pilot our camera
what is it ctrl alt p
ctrl shift p
ctrl shift p all right
and then i want the aspect ratio i want
to adjust the aspect ratio
of the camera so in the camera settings
let's see
focal length aperture
film back i think this is it
custom ratio
so it's a 2 3
setup so the height would be
200 and this would be 300.
but that's all crazy let's try twenty by
thirty first the other way around thirty
by twenty
something like that
full frame dslr yeah i feel like full
frame dslr is what
what this is
two by three or maybe we go super
cinematic with it let's go let's go
cinematic with it because we're gonna
film something
with this um let's go 16.9 film yeah
this is what we want
this is what we want and let's do
let's go in our post process volume and
enable all this ray tracing
craziness i know we want to get a lens
flare in there i want to get closer to
uh our reference image and if
if you guys can help me out that would
be appreciated so we'll do
where is it
here see how it like it's darker it's
much darker
um and we have some subtle glowing here
it's not insane
this is what i want to achieve in unreal
and i'm going to need y'all's help to
to figure that out it's way too bright
okay
i'm using a directional light it's
i don't know if it's the sky atmosphere
no the sky dome
or the sky light i don't think it's any
of that stuff
i think it's just my exponential height
fog
and that's that's doing everything it's
way too intense
i'm almost wondering if i just need
atmosphere
so like i have this this light here
do i just need like an atmosphere uh
volume
atmosphere fog
and if we hide our directional light
like
how do i get this kind of like
night timey where did i put that image
change my fog color okay i think my
computer
did i just crash this what's going on
so this is certainly the reference yeah
i i guess i need to
adjust my skylight also okay so the fog
is too dense maybe
i should just hide the fog for a second
directional light all right we have a
directional light
the fog is really intense and you said
my skylight
type skysphere into the search drop down
your scene and rotate the sky 180 and
then click this guys here again and
refresh
the material there's a lot of options
yeah it's tough to follow
what to do alright adjust the skylight
let's try that
light color skylight color all right
maybe it's like a dark
bluish green somewhere
and here
like that maybe
so is this like yeah i feel like this
isn't doing what i want it to do
i in in um cinema 4d i want to use it
as like a colored hdri so it's just
lighting the whole thing with a certain
color
um do i have to refresh all this stuff
or build my lighting like how
how does that work
so right now it's just a black void
being lit with a spotlight
marthal arts says the sky sphere is
adding a sky to your scene and stars by
rotating the directional light you
change the day or night cycle
and you have to bind the sky sphere to
the directional light
okay so directional light
needs to be bound to my
my skylight or no
where's my sky sphere
skydome mesh okay so this is
closer to what i want
this is way intense
yeah why is that so intense do i need
just a darker fog
yeah i'm having i'm having trouble with
this i don't really know how to
control this here
and that bloom is ridiculous
so the sky sphere needs to be attached
to
the directional light do i just group
those
and then adjust the directional light
i'm gonna out of let's see
out of the camera why the shortcut
doesn't work i don't know
and now my directional light isn't
moving i'm just confused at this point
so that's coming from that way
that would be my directional light
coming from this way
but my sky sphere is coming from that
way
instead of what do i just have to line
these up
ah but because they're grouped jeez okay
ungroup all right
dude i keep moving the wrong thing oh my
god
all right so now they're grouped
so when i move my directional light
it should all move together
but why that's not yeah i don't i don't
know melanie
thank you thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you
getting that domino's video out was one
heck of a process
um i was up until midnight every single
night for the last two weeks
so thank you so much um
does my knee still hurt from the
tortoise
chat with the jumping jacks um it's it's
getting better
it's getting better that was a mistake
certainly a mistake
um i just want to run again i just want
to
i just want to be running but um it's
getting better yeah i'm doing some
physical therapy for it and
uh are you streaming normally next
saturday
i will not be streaming next saturday
for you guys who are wondering
um i'm going to post my c graph
presentation instead so that's going to
be a 55 minute tutorial
i'm going to walk you guys through the
whole process of
creating photo real renders in cinema 4d
and octane i also go over some redshift
options as well
and then you integrate it into your live
action footage we're talking about
tracking
and compositing as well so that'll be
next saturday
i'll probably upload that at like 9 00
a.m for those of you guys who are
up late on the other side of the world
or up early
on this side of the world so that'll be
an exciting
sea graph presentation for y'all because
i'm gonna be on vacation
it's my birthday actually too on friday
july 31st is my birthday
i'm excited for that it's gonna be good
okay um
back in there's just so much
oh man there's so much
i don't know how to get i don't know how
to control the lighting in this thing
man that's my problem
i think we were close at a certain point
like oh that's cool
so that's just the
point light i'm sorry that's that's a
spotlight and the exponential height fog
but that light is is pretty intense so
let's see i'm gonna get to this phone
setting up our phone to actually like
orbit around this scene
man i feel like i'm unorganized here
we don't need a player start the point
light i think is
overkill let's see
let's see if we can't get a a lens flare
going
on our post process volume
so under lens flare we can just check
that on
and get a really nice lens flare going
well i don't know why that streak is
happening i don't like that streak at
all but we can take the lens flare
and take it to like .1.01
intensity so it's just very very subtle
something like that i think is really
really nice and it adds a lot
yeah i got too much going on there's
there's too many too many things i don't
really know
how to work here um
i might just start from scratch on the
lighting real quick
i got a sky sphere the directional light
will keep
the exponential height fog will keep
um sky atmosphere sky dome
skylight no maybe not
skylight the atmospheric fog we can get
rid of
the sky sphere let's get rid of the sky
sphere
and the directional light
and let's just start i don't know why
that's not showing up
it's just darkness
i wonder if it's because of my fog
yeah it's the fog
the scattering color is like really dark
jeez melanie whoa
holy crap um
[Music]
that's amazing okay a fellow july child
your birthday's in july as well you're
getting your birthday gift early then
thank you happy birthday and thank you
for being such an awesome talented
wholesome and inspiring human being
thank you melanie you're the best thanks
for coming
to these streams every single week um do
more
do more nice stuff for yourself rest up
you deserve it thank you so much that is
really really really kind of you thank
you melanie you're amazing
i wow i'm lucky to have you in these
things
thank you so much that means so much
thank you thank you
thank you i will certainly enjoy my
birthday i need the break i've been
working so hard
that's awesome thank you so much thank
you
shoot man you guys are awesome
oh man i wish i could figure this out i
wish i could get good with this
my exponential height fog that's what's
killing me
fog density 0.1
0.5 maybe
let's go with this for now all right i'm
gonna go with this for now
um let's go and hit up our post process
volume we want that uh
that lens flare so maybe we get that
lens flare back up
and you can actually mess with all of
this stuff
so you can go under let's see
bokeh size and threshold you can crank
these
but you don't want to go too intense
with it
and you can actually like change out all
of the act
the individual bits here image effects
yeah let's go with a little bit of
vignette i'm down for that
and we can actually color correct to our
shadows
mid-tones and highlights you have full
control of like all of this stuff it's
really crazy
and unreal
melanie i'm still blown away by that
that's that's amazing thank you thank
you thank you so much
it's so kind of you
ray tracing yeah we'll leave all the ray
tracing on check for a second just
because
we don't have too much bounce light
let's get this camera hooked up all
right guys
let's talk about how to hook up your
phone to uh
to unreal engine so i'm going to just
have to point y'all
um if you really want to know how to do
this winbush has an awesome tutorial on
on this whole process so i'm not going
to start to say all the exact little
details of how to do this and how to do
that
but winbush is the guy just look up win
bush unreal
um iphone or ipad and i'll probably just
drop a link to his video in the
description so that you guys can check
that out that's how i learned
let me build my lighting real quick
while i set this up so
you need a couple things you got to get
the the app on your phone
and it's called you remote 2 unreal
remote 2
all right you type in your ip address
which you can find by going
to let's see
actually i'm not gonna do it because i i
did it before i don't know if it saved
it but you're gonna hit cmd
command prompt you're gonna open up your
command prompt and you're gonna type uh
what is it um
ipconfig i think is the
is the uh what you need to type for that
ipconfig
and it'll pull up your ip address you
type that into the the app here
on your phone and then you open
up let's see your take recorder
and your sequencer okay
and let's just try i'm going to connect
and see what happens
so it's connecting now it may
i may have to do something
like a step that i'm forgetting i feel
like i'm forgetting a step here
what was it it was uh
i got my take recorder i got my
sequencer
do i need to check all of these
buttons again i might have to
all right so i know that if i go to
world settings
oh game mode all right you need to go
virtual camera mode
game mode alright
and then i need to go to my
settings plugins
and we'll go to built in
virtual all right enable you want to
enable all these plugins
and then i feel like there was something
else let me try it again connect
it's that world setting you want to set
that world setting virtual game
uh virtual camera game mode
where was it cinematics
where where is it
what am i missing when bush
i know i'm missing something
let's pull it up let's pull up mr
wimbush
win bush um
ipad unreal
yeah if you don't know winbush's channel
he's a super solid dude
um we've been talking a lot actually
pretty recently
this guy is really nice really humble
passionate about what he does
um and he's gonna walk us through how to
do this
so i don't know if you guys can hear
um winbush going here but i'm i'm just
gonna
briefly reference this off to the side
hopefully you guys got this you guys
channel wimbush how to use your ipad as
a virtual camera you can use your iphone
too all right
so i'm gonna just bring this over and uh
make sure i'm hitting all the check
boxes here so certainly we need to go
to where is it where is it
like we just did we went to settings
plugins
and we typed in virtual we went to built
in we typed in
virtual production you want to check all
four of these
so winbush is walking us through that
and then he's got us going over to
window cinematics you want your take
recorder
and your sequencer open so you want your
take recorder going
and that's what that's what this is
right here
my take recorder is going right here
so he's opening that up
and then he changed his world settings
game mode is set to virtual camera game
mode
oh it was the ipad oh it was the iphone
set
okay okay it was under settings
project settings um
oh there was some okay where is it i'm
gonna find it for you real quick
you just need to tell it what phone you
have um
what version of iphone or or ipad and
we're gonna find out right now if you
can do it on android
all right so we made a camera
this camera's in the scene game mode
virtual camera game mode
and then wind bush is saying that's not
all you have to tell it what phone you
have
alright so project settings we're here
input
mobile you want to always show touch
interface have that checked
and then where is it there's one last
one
we'll go edit editor preferences
and under was it play
yeah under play game viewport settings
go to phones and it looks like it does
all the phones
i have an xr
and i'll close that out and now it
should work
so i've selected my phone let's connect
to the ip address
oh where's he going he's going play new
editor window
oh shoot there it was
this is it
yo
all right so i'm moving this around
and can film the scene like this
this is crazy all right so oh this is so
cool
and you can actually move around so
there's a little joystick
um where you can like walk and stuff you
hit this little button
down here you can like walk around so i
want to go
i want to go back and you can like boom
up and boom down
because you can't really walk around
right because it's too
my room's obviously not big enough but i
can walk around and get a cool shot
so i'm just backing up with my like
thumb controls here
and if i go down
like how cool is that
that is amazing and you can actually
mess with like uh
your focal length so if i go uh
24
and you can like frame up your shots and
then you can also you can
connect your phone like physically mount
your phone to any sort of like camera
that you have if you have like a black
magic or something
and you can hold it on a camera rig so
it feels more like a legit camera than
just an iphone you know
um and you can yeah orbit around your
scene and like walk up to everything i
can like walk up to this
to this wood here if i actually move
forward in 3d space
you know i can like get up on that and
stuff so that it's so freaking cool
and i wish there was a way to like
orient around so like
i could be looking at my scene by
pointing
in this direction but yeah it's it's
back there
and you have auto focus up here
with the a i think is auto focus
so it's just going to autofocus to
anything you want and let me like move
up to this
dana
so it's going to auto focus to this wood
here
how cool is that
that's amazing
yeah this is powerful this is why i
think this is the future like if you can
get a really nice scene go in
you can film all this cool stuff i'm
just
really excited for this
you can film a whole scene you know set
it up nice
so what'd you guys think about that
that's pretty sweet huh
thanks to to win bush
walking me through that
all right um
did that work for y'all did you catch
that or did i lose you guys because i'm
getting an error it says youtube is not
receiving enough
video to maintain smooth streaming was
that chunky for y'all or did you see it
give me a little thumbs up yeah
[Music]
dang
so y'all didn't see any of that did you
let me know as soon as i get that thumbs
up i'll know that we're good
can you guys hear me thumbs up thumbs up
if you can hear me
are we back in do we got a healthy
stream once again
dang sorry you guys missed all that
stuff
next time next time um
when i get more of the hang of it
definitely check out uh winbush's
tutorial though if you're trying to get
that
up and running in unreal engine winbush
is your guy
for that um he certainly got me set up
to do so
and i'm really excited to mess with it
so
that was awesome
all right so we're all good now we got
the gist of it you guys are good
awesome
that might be about it guys let's issue
this next challenge
this week's weekly challenge all right
so my challenge to you guys
i got this one my challenge to you guys
is to create
an isometric
level like this
it can be very simple along these lines
here
or you can go to town and do this whole
dealie
or something like this but i've been
loving this style there's an instagram
account called like low poly guru or
something
um
i think low poly
like this kind of stuff you know um
this is called an itram isometric view
it's a view that you can actually set up
pretty easily i'll show you real quick
in cinema before we wrap out
but it's cool because like um all of
your angles
there there are only hard lines you're
not gonna have like a wide angle lens
where you're getting like this distorted
boat out kind of stuff
you're getting this kind of setup where
it's like a video game or old school
video game or like xcom or something
so that's my challenge to you guys
create an isometric
um scene an isometric scene that's what
we'll call it
so real quick in cinema i'm gonna show
you how to set that up
let's open up um
let's open up our street lamp file
and we'll make make a new camera
once cinema 4d catches up with us
we'll hop in all right and so the trick
with an isometric view
it's very it's very specific what you
want to do
is select your camera
and you're going to go like focal length
well actually before we change the focal
length let's
mess with the rotation so it's got to be
negative 45
and negative 45 maybe
so technically this is isometric i'm
going to rotate
my geometry
something like this and the trick is you
never want to change the rotation the
rotation of your camera has to be locked
so negative 45 and negative 45
and what you're going to do is zoom way
the heck out
and then zoom way in with your camera so
you're going to go like a 200
and this is an isometric view
it's a really long lens and your
rotation
is 45 degrees by 45 degrees so you're in
there
and then anything that you create so if
it's like a cube you can see how that
cube
right it's going to look uh
geometrically it's going to have like a
certain style certain shape would be
presented in a certain way
so when you build out your walls or
whatever
you can
make your floor
like this
i think this is a really fun style i'm a
huge fan of like old video games and
stuff
and this is definitely reminiscent of
that style they used it a lot in those
games
and i'll just render the scene and see
what it looks like
so visual it can be realistic it doesn't
have to be cartoony but it definitely
needs to be
an isometric scene all right that's the
challenge for this week is an isometric
scene if you guys have any questions
i'll be in the discord server um
probably for the next
20 minutes right after i cut this off
here
um but yeah i'll post the challenge in
the discord server so that you guys can
follow along and and put out all of your
submissions
during the week and what i'm gonna do
instead of uh
announcing the winners on the stream i'm
just gonna announce them in the discord
server
again because i'll be on vacation i will
not be streaming next week
i'll be posting my maxon presentation on
my channel instead
okay so definitely look out for that
but yeah that's just a good little
breakdown on the isometric view
your camera again it's like a 200 or a
300 millimeter
focal length you're zoomed way out you
know your camera's pushed way back and
your rotation is
negative 45 and negative 45.
but have fun with it um super fun
very very fun yeah it's kind of like an
orthographic camera
but y'all i'm gonna do it i'm finally
doing it i'm going on vacation
i need it if you hadn't seen the domino
video go to corridor and check it out
um if you want some cool hdris i got
that pack up
i'm not going to forget about the
winners i'm i'm giving you all the pack
the hdri warzone pack
for free on me check out the skillshare
link
you guys got two free months to learn to
learn whatever the heck you want all
right so check that out it helps me out
um when they see a lot of a lot of y'all
going to the links that i'm pushing then
it's good
good for me good for all of us um
what else what else yeah check out my
hdri my custom hdri tutorial it's on my
channel
if you haven't seen that already but
y'all about to lose my voice
so i'ma catch you later have a good week
and uh i'll see you guys
i'll see y'all soon probably in the next
two weeks but i'll be on the discord
server
peace